la gouvernance mondiale celle et les
européens après napoléon c'est chez nous
en 1918 etc des alliés des mendiants 45
si les occidentaux après la fin de lurs
qui dictent leur loi
ça n'a pas toujours été raté d'ailleurs
ce qui a été fait en 45 et bien plutôt
intelligent mais aujourd'hui la
gouvernance mondiale sastre et qui serez
qui a lorsque vous avez des 200 pays des
nations-unies médiature d'avant ce
qu'ils sont d'accord sur rien ou alors
c'est qui les puissances dominantes ces
états unis chine
imaginons que augmenterait dans un bras
de fer qui se transforme en guerre
froide qui va durer longtemps
les états unis et la chine se dit non
allez on va se mettre d'accord entre
nous on va organiser le monde
qu'est-ce qu'on va poser nous par
rapport à ça on l'a on parle de
souveraineté européenne c'est bien il
faut la construire
il donne un contenu mais elle existe pas
pour le moment on dit qu'il faudrait pas
avoir à choisir entre les les
technologies américaines et chinoises
mais ret aujourd'hui donc c'est un
objectif
donc les gouvernance mondiale je pense
potasse est inatteignable a pas de
risque mais je ne crois pas que je suis
une bonne réponse elle incitait part
connu une meilleure coopération
meilleure information une même équipe
plus informés qui peut aller plus vite
une réaction internationale plus rapides
dans les prochains épisodes vont à on
gagne plusieurs semaines maison s'il est
si l'alerté fait précocement rien et on
met en commun
justement les leçons qu'on aura tiré de
vos premières questions s'il faut
confiné comment on fait ici vaut tester
comment on fait c'est là il peut y avoir
des progrès énormes dans la coopération
internationale et c'est pas la
gouvernance mondiale s'est pas de vous
aurez jamais le président mondial du
peuple mondial ça existe pas sain
[Musique]